une nuée de journalistes caméras
photographes tous réunis jeudi dernier
pour la sortie de prison d'un rappeur et
de son avocat chanteur activistes il est
devenu le symbole d'une jeunesse qui
veut la révolution j'étais un peu
choqués effrayés mais après cela je veux
confirmer que je continuerai à vouloir
me battre à notre manière ce que nous
avons dit est légale et autorisée par la
constitution
et quand viendra le moment de la
modifier ou de rédiger une nouvelle
nous devrons continuer à soulever
activement les questions relatives à ce
nouveau projet de constitution
l'artiste accompagné d'autres militants
ont été libérés sous caution après avoir
participé à des manifestations contre le
gouvernement et la monarchie des sujets
tabou en thaïlande des manifestants
poursuivis pour sédition ou encore
violation de la loi d'urgence sanitaire
chaque jour des centaines voire des
dizaines de milliers de thaïlandais se
rassemblent pour donner de la voix sur
les campus universitaires
certains étudiants n'ose pas dire la
vérité car la société thaïlandaise leur
apprend qu'ils doivent écouter les
adultes et obéir à leurs ordres il n'ose
pas dire la vérité
il n'ose même pas y penser mais
aujourd'hui nous nous exprimions et nous
allons mettre fin à cette vieille
tradition ce problème s'arrête avec nous
le temps est venu pour nous de sortir et
de protester contre la dictature
nos trois ont été supprimés pendant si
longtemps des événements ou des choses
que nous avons eues en ligne nous ont
montré que nous ne pouvons pas de rien
faire en ligne de mire le premier
ministre prayut chan o cha qui
cristallise toutes les tensions l'an
passé cet ancien chef de l'armée
à l'origine du coup d'état de 2014 a été
réélu après des élections législatives
controversées
aujourd'hui les opposants réclament
trois mesures fortes la démission de
prayut chan-o-cha la dissolution du
parlement et la réécriture de la
constitution constitution
qui donne un large pouvoir aux deux cent
cinquante sénateurs tous choisis par
l'armée pendant ce temps le gouvernement
fait la sourde oreille
parfois chaque échelon des institutions
liées à du harcèlement
si certains décident de ne pas se
joindre à la contestation
alors ils sont harcelés pour ne pas se
joindre au groupe ou aux bandes d'amis
ce qui est vraiment dangereux il ya deux
semaines plusieurs activistes s'étaient
même réunis devant le parlement pour
proposer 10 amendements concret afin de
réformer la monarchie un message
directement adressé au roi de thaïlande
rama ix multimilliardaire critiqué pour
ses dépenses somptuaires
dans un pays où la pauvreté est monnaie
courante dans leurs manifestations les
étudiants en leur signe de ralliement
ruban blanc salut à trois doigts tout
droit inspiré du film hunger games
un signe de défi mais qui reste
pacifique